ralph brinkhaus höhe die unionsfraktion
wird ja schon seltsam dass herr gauland
gerade beklagt dass nicht genügend
geimpft wird gegen eine pandemie die
seine fraktion seit einem jahr
bestreitet also es ist eine seltsam kite
also was hier argumentiert für die liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist glaube ich auch nicht die
einzige seltsamkeit die wir momentan
haben
es ist richtig wir sind jetzt im
dreizehnten monat einer epidemie von
nationaler ausmaßes wir sind im zweiten
lok tor wir haben die bundeskanzlerin
hat es gesagt mittlerweile den zweiten
virus und wir sind alle müde wir sind
müde das ist überhaupt keine frage viele
menschen sind wütend viele menschen sind
zwar nicht und gerade in diesem
augenblick halte ich es für wichtig auch
mal den blick über deutschland hinaus
nach europa zu werden und das ist ja
auch der sinn dieser debatte und das war
klar zu machen weil es leute gibt die
sagen wir sind eine insel wie sollen
national zuerst an uns denken und dann
reicht das
wir haben neuland außengrenzen mit
ländern wie dänemark von dem wir
zugegebenermaßen einiges lernen können
in der pandemie und ländern wie
tschechien wo überhaupt nichts klappt
alle personen die von ost nach west von
nord nach süd über den landweg durch
europa reisen reisen durch deutschland
kein land ist in den
wertschöpfungsketten so europäisch
vernetzt wie deutschland das ist und was
wäre unser arbeitsmarkt ohne die 24
stunden pflegerin aus polen ohne die
bauarbeiter und die logistiker und ohne
die erntehelferinnen und erntehelfer aus
rumänien bulgarien vom balkan
europa europa meine damen und herren ist
für uns keine frage europa ist keine
option europa ist unsere wirklichkeit
und deswegen können wir diese bande mir
auch nur europäisch lösen neue damen und
herren
und weil das so ist ist es auch wichtig
dass wir in dieser zeit solidarität üben
europäisch und darüber werden wir in
einer späteren debatte abstimmen ja es
ist richtig dass wir in der krise helfen
ja es ist richtig dass wir in der krise
mit dem eigenmittel beschluss mit dem
neustart paket etwas außergewöhnliches
auf den weg bringen aber meine damen und
herren das ist die ausnahme in der krise
das ist die solidarität in der krise
und deswegen ledig ist total ab was olaf
scholz und die afg aus unterschiedlichen
gründen behaupten dass das nämlich der
einstieg in eine dauerhafte fiskal und
schulden union ist das ist es für uns
definitiv nicht meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und es ist auch wichtig dass wir diesen
impfstoff europäisch gemeinsam
geschaffen aus den gründen die ich
gerade genannt habe und natürlich ist es
so dass es vielleicht besser gewesen
wäre für uns national alleine aber nicht
langfristig wenn wir das diesen stoff
alleine beschafft hätten aber trotzdem
trotzdem ist es richtig dass wir das
gemeinsam als europäerinnen und europäer
gemacht haben ja wir müssen uns an
rechnen dass es schlechter geklappt hat
als den vereinigten königreich in israel
oder in den vereinigten staaten
ja es ist wichtig dass dieser gipfel
sich damit beschäftigt warum das so war
und dass die impfstoffversorgung
verbessert wird das ist überhaupt keine
frage
aber wir müssen uns auch fragen sind die
europäischen institutionen denn
überhaupt bereit dafür gewesen so eine
impfstoff beschaffung zu organisieren
haben wir nicht dysfunktional eaton in
ihrem europäischen institutionen und
deswegen bei aller kritik gegenüber den
handelnden personen in brüssel das muss
auch berücksichtigt werden wir müssen in
europa auch funktional besser werden für
diese krise und das muss eine lehre aus
dieser pandemie seien liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und wenn ich jetzt bei kritik an
handelnden personen bin dann möchte ich
mal nach deutschland zurückkehren
und ich möchte einfach mal noch vor
augen führen
mit welcher schärfe und mit welcher
kämen handelnden personen in der letzten
zeit hier kritisiert worden sind und ich
schließe mich dieser häme und schärfe
ausdrücklich nicht an
weil nämlich entscheidungen getroffen
worden sind und die meisten
entscheidungen waren im übrigen auch
richtig ich schließe mit dieser häme und
schärfe nicht an weil diese entscheidung
und
unsicherheit und im risiko getroffen
worden sind ich schließe nicht dieser
käme nicht an weil wir mittlerweile eine
unkultur in diesem land haben dass
jegliche fehler als skandal als versagen
oder als versagen mit vorsatz bezeichnet
werden wo sind wir denn meine damen und
herren
und wenn wir diese träger kultur weiter
fortführen dann wird niemand mehr fehler
zugeben da werden fehler vertuscht und
dann können wir auch nicht lernen und
deswegen sollten wir uns überlegen wie
wir mit fehlern in diesem land umgehen
sollten nach vorne schauen und sollten
daraus lernen
aber eins ist auch richtig und das ist
überhaupt keine frage ich habe gerade
gesagt europa ist in teilen
dysfunktional für diese krise
aufgestellt gewesen
das gleiche gilt auch für unser land und
nein ich möchte nicht den föderalismus
in frage stellen aber die aufgaben und
verantwortung zuordnung im föderalismus
war für diese krise schlecht und da
beißt die maus keinen faden ab
die inneren verwaltungsabläufe die wir
haben sind nicht schnell und nicht
flexibel und ich agieren wir übrigens
nicht nur für die krise sondern für
viele andere herausforderungen auch und
um das ganz klar zu stellen das liegt
nicht an den menschen die in der
verwaltung arbeiten sondern das liegt
einen politischen rahmen den vielen ja
auch im deutschen bundestag setzen
und wenn herr lindner wir waren
parlamentsbeteiligung reden da müssen
wir darüber reden wie wir einen neuen
rahmen schaffen dass dieses land besser
und flexibler auf die herausforderungen
der gegenwart und zukunft reagieren kann
die kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen und die bundeskanzlerin hat
gesagt und übrigens haben wir da mehr
auf den weg gebracht als das öffentlich
scheint wir müssen die digitalisierung
vorantreiben und der bundesinnenminister
hat auch gesagt und arbeitet daran wir
brauchen eine neue philosophie für den
nationalen katastrophenschutz sowie das
jetzt funktioniert kann es nicht
weitergehen
und deswegen habe ich auch gesagt wir
brauchen in diesem land nicht nur eine
reform sondern wahrscheinlich sogar eine
kleine revolution auf diesen land auf
diesen staatswesen liegt der staub von
200 jahren und diesen staub hier müssen
wir jetzt spätestens in der krise
beseitigen
aber das ist auch eine wahrheit für die
aktuelle pandemie können wir nicht auf
eine revolution warten da müssen wir
handeln
dann müssen wir schnell handeln und
gestatten sie mir diesbezüglich ein
gedanken ich bin wie viele kolleginnen
und kollegen auch in die politik rein
gegangen um lebens zu erschüttern um
leben zu ermöglichen das ist die
motivation für uns leben vom anfang bis
zum ende zu schützen und leben zu
ermöglichen
weil ich zutiefst davon überzeugt bin
dass leben die voraussetzung für
freiheit ist das leben und gesundheit
die voraussetzung für die
inanspruchnahme von grundrechten ist und
das leben die voraussetzung dafür ist
und auch gesundheit dass ich mein leben
eigenverantwortlich gestalten kann
und wenn das so ist dann kann ich das
natürlich nicht absolut setzen klar ich
muss es immer wieder ausbalancieren den
wert des lebens gegen andere werte das
ist überhaupt keine frage
aber man kann dann von mir als politiker
erwarten dass sich priorisieren und
wendig priorisieren dann stelle ich fest
dass sich heute über 20.000 menschen neu
infiziert haben das heute weit über 200
todesfälle gemeldet worden sind das sind
im übrigen ungefähr so viele leute wie
hier jetzt im saal sitzen 200 gesichter
200 schicksale 200 hoffnungen 200
enttäuschung 200 x lite und das jeden
tag und nicht nur heute nicht nur
gestern nicht nur vorgestern und das
muss auch das primat unseres handelns
sein dass wir dieses leben schützen ja
und wir müssen vielleicht auch neben den
leuten die wir immer im blick haben zu
recht im blick haben die gastwirte die
einzelhändler die menschen die sich
danach sehnen soziale kontakte haben ist
es doch auch unsere aufgabe diejenigen
im blick zu haben die nicht laut sind
das sind die schwachen die zu hause
bleiben müssen
das sind die überlasteten
intensivpfleger das sind die menschen
die mit langzeit erfolgen erkrankt sind
und das sind die menschen die einen
elenden tod gestorben sind und im
übrigen wenn jetzt jüngere menschen
erkranken dann werden sie einen noch
elender
und deswegen ist es unsere verantwortung
was für diese menschen zu tun und
natürlich hilft testen natürlich hilft
impfen aber seien wir doch mal ehrlich
das wird in den nächsten wochen nicht
reichen und deswegen ist eine große
währung die wir in den nächsten wochen
haben immer noch die kontakt
beschränkung und diese entscheidung
müssen wir treffen wir werden die
bundeskanzlerin hat es gesagt nicht nur
das licht sehen sondern wir werden
wahrscheinlich im sommer heraus kommen
aber es ist unsere entscheidung wie
viele menschen auf diesem weg noch
erkranken und sterben werden und vor dem
hintergrund haben wir auch die
entscheidung der ministerpräsidenten
konferenz zu bemessen und bei allem
respekt ich glaube wir haben an der
stelle noch nicht genug getan um diese
schwachen um diese potenzielle kranken
dann auch entsprechend zu schützen und
da sollten wir uns überlegen was wir
noch tun können
schlussbemerkung es ist so dass ich am
anfang meiner rede gesagt hat ja das
land ist unruhig viele menschen
bürgerinnen und bürger journalistinnen
und journalisten politikerinnen und
politiker sind zornig und sintflut ist
ein schleichendes gift was in unser land
einsickert das gift der wut und
natürlich kritik ist notwendig das
ringen um die besten konzepte ist
unverzichtbar fehler müssen benannt
werden
und im übrigen ja auch persönliches
fehlverhalten muss konsequent bestraft
werden und jeder der handelt muss sich
auch verantworten
aber bitte lasst uns auf diesen weg
zusammen bleiben denn wenn wir nicht
zusammen bleiben wenn wir es gestatten
dass die wut in diesem band land gewinnt
dann ist das das gift was viel schlimmer
ist als das virus was uns momentan
beschäftigt und in dem sinne wünsche ich
uns dass wir den nächsten wochen
zusammen dem weg gehen bis wir durch
geimpft sind und unser altes leben
wieder zurückkam
[Applaus]